JASON SANDERS: Thank you for
joining us for another Talks
at Google event.
We're lucky enough to be
joined today by Meb Keflezighi.
[APPLAUSE]
Meb is, of course, a man
who needs no introduction.
Shortly after immigrating to
the United States in 1987,
Meb discovered he was
a natural born runner.
And the rest, as
they say, is history.
He's won more than
20 national titles.
You're the former
American record
holder in the 10,000 meter.
You're the only runner in
history, American or otherwise,
to have won Boston, New
York, and an Olympic medal.
[APPLAUSE]
And you're the founder of the
Meb Foundation, a nonprofit
which funds programs
that promote
fitness and other positive
lifestyle choices for children.
And so without further
ado, let's talk to Meb.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
Thank you, Jason.
JASON SANDERS: So thanks
again for joining us today.
Congratulations on
another top 10 performance
on Monday in Boston.
I know, though, that the race
didn't go exactly how you'd
hoped, especially that last 5K.
You've had a couple days
to think about it now.
Do you have any
thoughts about the race?
I know people have asked
you a lot about this.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Yeah.
Most definitely.
It's a great honor
to be here at Google.
And thanks for the opportunity.
It was a great honor to
represent the United States
over my career, but
especially last year,
to be able to win the Boston
Marathon on the most important
day, on Monday, after
the bombing of 2013,
to help expedite the
healing process of the many
that got affected.
And unfortunately we can't get
the lives back that we lost.
But I tried to do
something really positive.
That was my goal.
And this year, going
into the 2015 Boston,
my whole goal was just make
it over Heartbreak Hill
and the last two, three
miles-- two miles, actually--
and everything will play itself.
Use the support of the crowd.
And the race unfolded
the way I anticipated it
would, and stayed [INAUDIBLE].
It was really windy,
so I tucked in behind,
didn't do crazy moves.
A lot of people were doing
sprint, slow, sprint, slow.
And I was in the back, just
kind of taking a mental note who
was doing that, and
I was going to come
to hunt them at the end.
So I was looking
forward to the crowd
and to the last mile,
mile and a half.
And unfortunately, with
about three miles to go,
I had an upset stomach, and
I guess I had eaten lunch.
It's not a good scenery
for it, but I had
to stop five times in between.
And I was trying
to close the gap,
because they made the move.
And the water, the
fluid wouldn't go down
as I was trying to sprint,
and stopped five times.
And basically, just I
didn't have the opportunity
that I was anticipating in
the last mile, mile and a half
to use the crowd to help propel
me forward to go to Boston
and stay for another,
try to defend the title.
But sometimes you don't
always get what you want
or what you desire.
You just gotta finish
the task that was ahead
and what is there for
you, you seize the moment.
And for me, just to come
across the finish line
in eighth place, as
Jason said, top 10,
anytime you finish at the
world's major marathon top 10,
is a great, great honor.
And you know, I feel strong.
And I was able to see a spot--
one of the elite women that was
running, she made me work hard.
I had to sprint really hard.
And I just got-- right before,
from here probably to the exit
sign there, I caught up to her
and raised her hand to say,
hey, we did it together.
And it was a great finish,
representing the United States.
JASON SANDERS: So
after Boston, we
appreciate you coming up to
New York here to join us.
I know you're based
in California.
You went to UCLA,
and then you were
based in Mammoth Lakes
and now San Diego.
But you seem to have very
strong ties to New York.
You've run the New York
marathon nine times.
You've been top 10
seven of those times,
and you w won it
in 2009, famously.
You've run the New York
half several times.
You've run even 10Ks in
Central Park a few times.
What is that keeps bringing
you back to New York?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: New York
is my second home here,
because I've won many
competitions, anywhere
from the 8K to the 10K,
Healthy Kidney, half marathon.
In fact, I was runner up in
the inaugural half marathon
in-- I believe it was in
2005, when it was in August,
when it was hot and humid.
And they changed it to a
tune-up for the spring marathon.
So the New York Road
Runners do a great job.
My first marathon was here in
2002, where I went for the win,
and it was a cold and
chilly morning, 38 degrees.
The water is outside.
And you know, when
you get 19 miles,
you kind of get a
little bit, maybe, warm.
And I'm like, I threw my
beanie away, my gloves away,
and put water over my head.
And that kind of
shut the engine off.
And I was doing really nice
rhythm, running like this,
started doing stomping.
And I got it down
to four people.
I said, best scenario,
I think I can still win,
and worst scenario
I got fourth place.
And I got slower and slower.
And the qualifying time for
the Olympics for the 2004 was
sub-2:12.
And I ran 2:12:35.
I missed it by 35 seconds.
But I always tell, the New York
City Marathon, the first time
I did it, I got my Ph.D. I
learned a lot what to do,
what not to do.
So since then, it's been
kind of like the relationship
that I have with the
New York runners,
who put on amazing events.
And I just keep coming back.
And as Jason said, I've
done it nine times.
Seven times I've
been in the top 10.
And people dream to come
to New York just to visit.
And we have the
privilege to run.
Those cities close, and do
[INAUDIBLE] through the five
boroughs and to be able to
come finish in Central Park
is really honored.
And the streets are closed,
because I can't even
get a taxi for 45
minutes sometimes.
So it's an honor
to be in New York
and be able to have that
relationship with them
and try to run the best
that I can every time.
And I've been-- like
you said, I won it.
I've been second place.
I've been third place,
been fourth place,
been sixth place twice, and
the first time I did it,
I was in ninth place.
So I struggled my first one,
but I kind of love, love,
love-- I do struggle.
In fact, the first time
I did the marathon,
I said, never again.
It was bad.
It was really bad.
I couldn't even walk or squat.
But at the same time, we
do forget some things,
and we want to do it again.
I'm glad I didn't make that
my last-- my mom was there,
the first time she saw me run
the marathon, both my parents
and my son.
It's OK to do 5K, 10K, but
no more marathons for you.
No mother wants to see her
son or daughter in pain,
and I was really in pain.
But you know, I got over it.
And in fact, I was
born in Eritrea.
So I went and visited.
And I understood
how life in Eritrea
is versus the United
States, because you
have to go three miles to
get water out of the well.
And you have to go
two, three miles
to get branches or
bark from a tree
to have fire to cook,
to boil the water,
and things like that.
So that made me realize the
pain that I was going through
in the last four, five
miles was not that bad,
so don't complain.
So I wanted to come back.
I said, coach, I'm ready
to do another marathon.
And I want to do Boston.
He said, wait a minute.
No, not yet.
So through marathons,
I have learned a lot.
JASON SANDERS: Yeah?
I think we're all grateful
that you, in this instance,
didn't listen to your mom.
Though I'm sure in most
instances, you did.
So marathoning has taken
you a lot of places.
But as a child, soccer was
actually your favorite sport,
right?
So how did you discover that
you were talented at running?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: I was born in
Eritrea where there was a war.
And you didn't have
the normal childhood,
and you didn't know what
the next day brings.
But the only fun thing probably
we did was play soccer.
And in fact, it was
makeshift soccer.
So arm warmers or
socks, long socks,
you stuff it in with plastic.
And you tie it and
then do a second layer.
And you sew it, so
you could have--
it's not like playing on the
grass or nice smooth air.
There's rocks and dirt
and all that stuff.
Barefoot, so the plastic
would make it bounce up high.
And that's how we played soccer.
And then eventually,
we just said--
we came to Italy, lived in
Italy for a year and a half.
My brothers and
sisters and my mom,
who were separated from
my dad for five years.
He has to walk from Eritrea to
Sudan, 225 miles in seven days
to save his life,
otherwise he's going
to get killed or prison
by [INAUDIBLE] soldiers.
And then we went
to Italy-- futbol,
that's what it's known there.
I used to play futbol.
And I got the nickname Pele.
So that was my nickname.
And I thought I'd be a
professional soccer player.
But then when we came
to the United States
in 1987, two, three
years later, I
heard my dad talk
about my brother's
doing soccer and running--
the soccer coach wants
him to play soccer year round.
The running coach wants
him to run year round.
So there was a little
bit of favoritism,
who was going to play,
who was not going to play.
So my dad just said, choose one
and do it well to my brother.
And that's when I
kind of let soccer go.
I could control my own destiny.
And running is beautiful
because you get out
of it what you put in it.
And you start here, you
finish there together.
There's no stopping in
between or judgmental things.
So it's whatever
effort you put in.
And I always say, run to win.
It doesn't mean
getting first place,
but getting the best out
of yourself each time
and every time on the moment.
JASON SANDERS: So let's talk
a little bit about the book,
"Meb For Mortals."
The elite running coach, Greg
McMillan, he's called you the,
quote, "king of
the little things."
I don't know if
you've heard that.
But to some extent,
this book is kind
of about all the little things.
Could you talk a little bit
about what those little things
really are and what you might
expect to find in this book?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: "Meb For
Mortals," it's a great honor
to have [INAUDIBLE] help me
out with it and Scott Douglas
to write the book.
And what it does
is, people think
you run 10 miles or 15 miles.
I got it.
But to have the longevity
and to have the consistency,
you have to do the small
things that make a difference.
People say, go the extra
mile, go the extra mile.
Really, you need to
take that one mile less
and emphasize on doing
stretches before or after,
doing the core exercise a
little bit before or after,
or doing the drills.
And are they boring or kind
of monotone at the same time?
Sure.
But those small things add up
to be big things down the road.
It keeps you injury free.
It helps you be stronger.
If you're stronger,
you're going to run more.
You're going to
be more efficient.
So that's what "Meb For
Mortals" discusses about.
And I don't like ice bath.
But I used to sit in the ice
bath for 15 minutes every day,
probably 340, 330 days a year.
And I used to shiver for four
or five hours afterwards.
And not fun, but
I know they were
essential to help me be-- have
an injury, you recover faster,
so you can do it day in,
day out, week in, week out,
month in, month out, and do it
for a long time over the years.
JASON SANDERS: So it's
about all the things
that maybe a recreational
runner is not
doing between runs
that would potentially
help them to achieve a
higher level, stay healthy?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Yeah,
most definitely.
I mean, I can't ask everybody
to be New York City champion
or Boston champion
or Olympic medals,
but you can use those principles
to apply it to nutritionally,
stretching-wise, core
wise, and training-wise,
to how it can help you be the
best that you individually
can be.
And if you see it--
and the book shows
a lot of illustration of
what to do, what not to do.
So if you can do that, it will
help you be the best you can.
JASON SANDERS: Right.
So you talk about being
the best you can be.
And some of the book is
about setting good goals,
that that's a big
part of the process.
So you are a couple of
weeks from turning 40.
You've said that winning
Boston last year-- you
don't seem it, by the way.
Winning Boston last year has
made your career 110% complete.
So what are some of the goals
you have for the next year?
I mean, the trials
are coming up.
Can we expect a masters
marathon record?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Yeah, I
mean, goals are recommend.
And you have to set them
weekly and yearly and whatnot.
But yes, the Boston
Marathon was the capping
of my running career, because
it started with seventh grade PE
class, trying to get an A,
trying to earn a T-shirt.
And who would have
ever thought I
would have that all in between?
And who would've ever
thought that also,
that it would be coming at the
biggest stage of the Boston
Marathon.
And the only thing that
was missing on my resume
was just the Boston title, and I
was able to get that last year.
So going forward, what my
goal is, in terms of running,
hopefully do a fall
marathon, hopefully New York.
And also the trials
are in February.
So if I could earn my spot,
top three, to go to Rio,
that would be my
fourth Olympic team.
And be 41, to participate in
it, it would be a huge honor.
And why do I want to do that?
Two things.
One is, every time you get
an opportunity to represent
our country, it's a huge honor.
And also, my daughters--
I have nine, seven,
and five years old daughters,
and they were all in London.
But the three-- she was three
at the time, five year old now,
she does not remember
what happened in London.
So it would be good for her to
see if I could make the team
and remember what her
daddy did as an Olympian.
JASON SANDERS: Right.
And so an important
part of this,
especially for
recreational runners,
is setting realistic goals.
You alluded before
to just missing out
on the Olympic marathon team
in Sydney by 35 seconds.
But you did end up going
to that Games, right,
and you competed in the
10,000 meters, correct?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: So missing
the New York was for 2004.
Sydney was my first
Olympic in the 10K.
JASON SANDERS: Right, OK.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: But I went to
Chicago-- setting goals, right?
I want to break 2:12.
And I ran 2:10:03.
And it's probably the
only time that I ever
went farther than 26.2, because
your body usually shuts down.
But that day, I was
just running 2:12.
I was very conservative.
And I finished, and I went for
a half mile cool down, which
is crazy, after a marathon.
But I made the 2004 team in the
10K, which I won the trials,
and set the championship record.
I was second in the
trials to Alan Culpepper.
And my times were
probably more realistic,
the medal in the 10K,
than was the marathon.
But because of the history
behind how the marathon started
was from Marathon to Athens,
what Pheidippides and announced
that they defeated the
Persians at Greece,
I couldn't turn it down, just
because of the historic moment
of it.
And the marathon is one
of the prestigious events.
And it was into the
closing ceremony,
even though my chances
were, like I said, better
to medal in the 10K with
the American record and all
that stuff.
But Coach Larsen, for a
long time my mentor now,
we decided go for the marathon.
The hills, the humidity, and the
course will equalize everybody.
So we went for that and came
home with a silver medal.
JASON SANDERS: And so the
10K that I'm thinking of
is the night of the finals,
your father said to you--
he's always pushed you.
And he said, Meb, you're
going to win tonight.
And so this is-- in
terms of realistic goals,
this is an example
where run to win
meant something
different to you, right?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
Absolutely, Jason.
So my dad in 2000, I
made the Olympic team.
I'm so excited to be on
my first Olympic team.
And my time was 28
minutes and three seconds,
which is fast but
not fast enough
to be a contender for the medal.
So we were going to the
stadium and he goes,
you're going to win tonight.
I was like, Dad, I
can't win tonight.
He's like, don't think that way.
You're going to win tonight.
I'm like, Dad,
they've run 26:30.
I have yet to break 28 minute.
And it's a minute and
a half in between.
That's more than a lap and
a half almost on the track.
So hopefully I won't get lapped.
But hopefully one day
I'll close the gap
and hopefully be
able to beat them.
And that's what happened.
And so I finished 12th.
I barely made the final.
In fact, they had a prelim
for the 10K on Friday,
Monday final.
I broke 28 minutes
on both occasions,
and I was the second-to-last
guy to qualify,
because I had the flu that
you get in the athletes'
village, where everybody's
there and gets--
the downside of the athletes'
village is you get sick,
and the flu that
was going around.
And I finished 12th overall.
And then 2004, four
years later, the guy
Paul Tergat from Kenya,
who was second at the 10K,
the greatest distance
runner in my book, I think,
Haile Gebrselassie, was
running the marathon.
And he was-- his best time
at the Athens Olympics
was two hours, four
minutes, and 55.
My best time was 2:10:03.
That's, if you look
at it, almost a mile.
The only way I could beat him
was if I get a mile head start.
But I know that
was not possible.
And basically-- and
I really did not
think he was going to
get beaten on that day.
For everybody else, silver
or bronze was fair game.
But for him, I would have almost
handed it to him, the gold.
And so we've got four people
going on through the race.
I'm like, my gosh, if
I can beat one person,
I'm going to be a medalist.
And then eventually, I start
over-striding, longer stride.
And I decide to
pick up the pace.
And I'm getting away from him.
I'm like, wow.
And the marathon, this was
only my fourth marathon ever.
So you're here, going
through the good patches
and the bad patches.
I'm like, he must be going
through the bad patches.
So I picked up the pace,
got it down to two people.
And there was one, de Lima
from Brazil, in front of us.
So like I say, I
got my bronze medal.
But I think I can get second
place, maybe going for gold.
So I tell Stefano
Baldini, which remember
I used to live in Italy
for a year and a half,
I just told him,
[SPEAKING ITALIAN] which
means, let's go get one, two.
And he looked at me.
He's like, how is this
guy speaking Italian?
In retrospect, I should
have made that move then,
kind of give him a double shock.
But he looked at
me, taking leads.
And we caught de Lima.
And unfortunately,
he was also the guy
got attacked-- I don't know
if you guys have ever seen it.
He got attacked in
the middle of the race
by an ex-priest that was
testifying that Sunday
should be a rest day.
But we did not see it happen
because it happened on a turn.
So I was able to
beat Paul Tergat, who
was the silver
medalist at the Olympic
when I finished 12th,
[INAUDIBLE] four years later.
My goal was to bring a
medal for the United States,
and I have to beat the world
record holder to do that.
And he finished eighth.
I finished second.
JASON SANDERS: That's amazing.
And so I guess the
moral there was
it took patience and
more investment and time.
And it's funny that Paul
Tergat, the guy that you beat,
because shortly before
the 2000 Olympics,
you sat down and had a
conversation with Paul, right?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Correct.
I mean, you have
to be realistic.
You have to make goals
that are attainable.
And I love crossing goals out.
Make that goal attainable.
Once you attain it, you
can always reset it.
Don't set it so high that
you cannot reach it or have
a stepping stone toward that.
And basically,
that's what I did.
And then I also met him
in '98, the first time.
I said-- in Brussels, hey, Paul.
I'd love to talk
to you about it.
And he took me around.
He took me for a drink, for tea.
And he mapped-- you need
to make small progress.
I can tell you all my secrets or
the workouts that I have done.
But you are at a
different level.
You're here, I'm here.
So to get up here, you've
got to do small things.
And that's what I did.
And I pass that advice
to everybody now.
Because if they ask me,
people, what should I do?
How many miles?
I have to know what you
are doing, because I can't
tell you to do this,
because I don't
know what your background is.
And sometimes you give advice,
and they come to haunt you.
Or sometimes you get advice,
and you'll be able to beat them.
JASON SANDERS: That's right.
You wrote a book for mortals.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: You know, it's
an honor to write the book.
And who would have ever
thought, for someone
who didn't speak
English coming here,
we didn't have
anything, no finance
but the clothes on
our back And the love,
the support of my brother
and sisters and my parents.
And to be able to
be here at Google
and to be able to talk
about the "Meb For Mortals,"
a book that I wrote.
And I just have to pinch myself
sometimes that this is real.
JASON SANDERS: I do as well too.
So you've mentioned a
few times, and you often
talk about running to win.
And we know that's not
always about coming in first.
And for a lot of us, we may
not ever win an Olympic medal.
I think that's a real
possibility that I'm starting
to face in my own life.
And you know from your
own experience as someone
who actually does win races that
it doesn't always mean winning.
And I think probably the
best example that I know of
is at the London Olympics.
And if you could talk
a little bit about what
your experience was there.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: You
know, run to win
doesn't always mean
getting first place
but getting the
best out of yourself
with the situation you're
faced with in that moment.
And Monday, before
even going to London,
I ran the best that I can that
day, and stopping five times,
I could just say, you know what,
I'm not defending my title.
I could stop and then
have the van pick me up.
But when you start a project,
you have to finish the project.
I really believe that.
And my parents have always
encouraged their kids
to do that.
You start something,
you must finish it.
And in London 2012, I didn't
have the ideal training.
Really, I had a really solid
five weeks of training.
And going through
the race, I'm like,
this guy's going
to go crazy fast,
and then maybe I can
pick up here and there,
little by little,
and finish maybe
for the bronze, the
only chance that I had.
But about halfway
through the race--
people often ask me
when I run marathons,
do you enjoy the scenery?
I'm like, not really.
I'm just going by and
trying to concentrate
on what I'm doing,
what others are doing,
trying to get
calculated decisions.
So I don't really
enjoy the scenery.
But in London,
I'm like, hm, this
would be a good place
to stop, because I
was hurting pretty bad.
I already had my Olympic medal.
I was 20th, 21st place.
I already have signed up
for New York City Marathon,
so don't do something
crazy, injure yourself.
But then I'm like, you know, I'm
representing the United States.
I have the USA jersey on me.
And ever since high school,
San Diego High, UCLA,
and world championship,
all the big teams,
you try to represent to the
country the best you can.
And when I made the
Olympic team in January
that year, 2012, I said,
we're sending our best team.
I hope we can represent
our country really well.
And I just said, you
know what, no matter
how many people pass me, I've
got to get to that finish line.
That's goal number one.
And I said, I'm representing
the United States.
My girls are there.
If I tell them to do their
best, and say if I stop now,
was that your best?
I'm going to get asked
that question eventually
when they get older.
So I just said, you know what?
Get to that finish line, no
matter what the circumstances
or how many people pass you.
And then I was closing
the gap, I said,
maybe I can beat one person
out of those eight people
that I was running with.
And then the next thing
is, maybe I could beat two,
maybe I could beat three,
so constantly changing.
And then all a sudden
is, I was in 15th place,
I was in 13th place.
And then with 5K to go, my
mentor Bob Larsen was there,
and he pointed out like this.
So I was running next
to the Japanese guy,
and I can see him.
And I was like, sixth place.
And I'm like, am I sixth
place, or the Japanese guy's
in sixth place?
I need to clarify here.
He didn't give me
a clarification.
And then I just said, so
basically-- and then I
see a green jersey down
the road with two miles
to go, probably like
30 second, 40 second.
I'm like, if that guy
is in fourth place--
this guy's in fifth
place, I'm in sixth place,
that guy's in fourth
place, for whatever reason,
our sport is kind of
tainted a little with drugs.
I'm like, if one of those guys
gets busted up in the front,
and that guy's in fourth place,
if I can beat the Japanese guy,
I'm going to be in fifth place.
So if somebody gets
caught, that guy's
going to move to
bronze medal, and I'm
going to move to fourth place.
I say, I gotta catch that guy.
And I just dug deep.
And with one
kilometer to go, there
was an American supporter
or a fan there, and he goes,
you can get him five seconds.
You can get him fast.
I was like, OK.
I get my head nodding.
I'm going to dig deep.
And then there's a picture
of us, me passing him,
with 500 meter to go.
So I'm in the front, the
500 meter sign, and then
him in the back.
And then I'm like-- so it's not
like the New York or the Boston
Marathon was a big finish line.
It's just a little
line like this.
But there's a ton of people.
I'm like, where's
the finish line?
Where's the finish line?
I'm digging deep.
I see the flag, our flag
and the Unites States.
I'm like, should I grab it?
Should I not?
This guy's trying to catch
me too that I just passed.
I'm like, I grabbed the flag,
I want it around like this,
but he's right on my heels.
I tucked in like this,
running, running, running.
And then I see little lines so
I raise our flag above my head
and finished fourth.
So run to win doesn't
mean getting first place.
But I felt like I was
a winner just because
from potentially dropping out
and not getting to the finish
line, finishing fourth and
passing all those people was
one of the proudest moments.
And dig deep, beyond
yourself for the country.
So run to win doesn't
always mean first place,
but getting the best
out of yourself,
each time, every time.
JASON SANDERS: Yeah, to
come back from one of those
rough patches is some of the
hardest thing that you can do.
Anyone who's run a
marathon knows that
and can identify with that
more than they can identify
with last year in
Boston, where you're
leading the pack for
pretty much the whole race.
For mortals, for the
inexperienced runners,
one of the hardest
things going into a race
is picking a goal, one or more
kind of pace or time goals,
or maybe it's to finish.
I imagine you sometimes
struggle with what
your goals need to be.
I know that you've
said, the first goal
is always to win, then
podium, then personal best.
But what are the workouts, what
are the benchmarks that you
have to know whether
or not you're in shape
to do a 2:08 or 2:10?
Or do you have certain things
that you go back to again
and again to kind of
evaluate where you're at?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Yeah.
I mean, some people ask me,
when you first meet somebody
and you tell them
you're a runner,
it's like, how often do you run?
I'm like, do you run every day?
I'm like, well, I
train 12 times a week.
They're like, what?
You run twice a day?
And I'm like, yeah.
That's what I do.
And those trainings,
there's a long run,
which for me, I cover as long
as 28 miles in preparation.
I'm done 16 miles, 15
mile tempo run, which
is about a five minute pace.
It's like that picture
there, I was going that fast.
JASON SANDERS:
That's that 7,000?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
That's that 7,000.
I'm going about a five minute
pace, 12 miles an hour.
And they captured that
moment right there, so kind
of hard work that's paid off.
And also intervals, so you
do faster than race pace,
so when I'm doing intervals,
I'm going 13 and 1/2, 13 miles
an hour, faster than race pace.
So you put all that together,
it gives you confidence
that, you know, faster than
race pace, race pace, and longer
than race pace.
But the hardest part
is staying healthy,
because I have the
desire, the motivation
to push my body to the limit.
And it got me in a lot of
trouble in the past also.
So now I expanded that training
cycle, seven days a week
to nine days cycle, so you
have two days between recovery.
So I run hard, two days
off, long run, two days off,
and tempo run, and
then two days off.
And it seems to be working.
But you just have to-- the
bread and butter for me
is tempos and long run.
But at the same
time, it just depends
what time you have available.
Routine is important.
Are you going to
do it after work,
or are you going to before work.
And then stick to it.
If you can do that consistently,
you will perform really well.
JASON SANDERS: So you talk about
how the really important thing
is to stay healthy.
You don't want to be the
fittest spectator at your race.
So maybe you could walk us
through what a typical warm up
before one of these
hard workouts or a race
would be for you.
When you started, what
kind of stuff do you do?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: So what
most people don't know
is that even, if
I'm running 5K, 10K,
a half marathon,
or a full marathon,
I always warm up three months.
So people say, you warm up
before you run a marathon?
But if you're going to start
a five minute pace, 12 miles
an hour, you have to do those.
So I do an hour before is
when I start my warm up.
And then it's like,
if it's really cold,
I break it up to two
segments, a mile and a half,
stretch, do the drills,
and then to keep warm,
go another mile and a half.
Otherwise there's Athens,
was hot and humid,
then seven minutes
is good enough,
just to let the body
know that you're
ready to go at
some kind of pace.
So I do eight strides
and then do the drills,
and then hopefully when the gun
fires off, I'm-- you know what,
as elite runners, we
never run our own race,
because if seven guys go world
record pace or faster than
the course record, you
have to make that decision.
If you want to challenge
for the win, you have to go.
Not all of them will
survive that pace,
but three will survive,
four will come back.
So do you want to
go for fourth place,
or do you want to go for a win?
Those are the decisions that
are made in mile one or mile 15
or mile 17 and all that.
But Boston Marathon last year,
I controlled most of the race.
And I ran my own race.
And I made the move with--
I was scared in Athens
to make a move, in
Athens Olympics 2004,
5K to go, I'm like,
that's a long way.
It's a long way, it's
only your fourth marathon.
But on your 20th marathon,
I ran out-- really,
it was seven, eight
miles into the race.
So 20 miles to go,
19 miles to go,
I made that move, make it count.
And it made that gap.
And then once I made that gap,
the mantra was Boston strong,
I'm going to give
them Meb strong.
If I get caught, I'm OK with it.
But I'm going to
run for the victims.
I'm going to run for Boston.
I'm going to run for United
States and the world.
And if they're
going to catch me,
they're going to
have to earn it.
So you have to have those
constant talks and whatnot,
and I was able to hold them off.
But experience pays big
dividends in training and also
in competitions.
JASON SANDERS: Right.
That was an amazing
win to watch.
So a lot of us, yourself
included, need to travel a lot.
How do you stay
on top of workouts
and all this stretching
and core stuff?
How do you stay on
top of that when
you're in unfamiliar
cities and hotels,
and maybe they don't have
the right facilities?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Well,
in terms of training,
you've got to have a watch.
That tells you--
I wear my Epson,
and that kind of comes into
distance, because sometimes I
used to do a lot of guesswork.
Oh, I'm going to go for
an hour and five minutes.
Is that 10 miles
or nine and a half?
But now you can get
pretty accurate.
But the hardest thing is
nutrition when you travel,
because I have my routine.
I like to have my toast, tea,
and almond butter or peanut
butter, before I go run.
But sometimes I'll just
have Generation UCAN, which
is one of my sponsors, or
have a Power Bar, half a Power
Bar in the hotel, have
a little tea, and go out
and come back, and get it done.
But the other important
thing is routine.
No, you have to sleep less.
I mean, do you want
to get up an hourly,
use that almost as your
caffeine, as your energy?
Or do you, especially when
you guys travel with work,
if you guys go with a group,
some people are sleeping in,
and all that stuff.
But you've got to get up.
For me, I like to get up in
the morning, get it done,
and get it over with.
You don't have to think
about it throughout the day,
because what to eat, what to
drink, and all that stuff,
you're constantly thinking
if you haven't done it
in the morning.
So get it done in the morning.
JASON SANDERS: Yeah.
So all this focus on
the things surrounding
the runs themselves,
you talk in the book
about how it's not when you're
running that you're actually
getting into better shape.
Could you talk about how
maybe as an elite runner,
your approach to
recovery differs
from what the recreational
crowd might be doing?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Famous
in basketball courts,
John Wooden said, it's not what
you do in practice, the two
hours, but how you take
care of yourself the next 22
hours-- sleeping,
nutrition, therapy, and also
icing or a massage, and
all those things add up,
doing the small things.
Yeah, you can have
a great workout
and say, oh, that
was a great 20 mile
run or five mile
run or 12 mile run,
but you've got to
take care of yourself.
And nutritionally
it's important.
It's always good to
graze throughout the day
than having big meals and
not feel good and then
have snacks around so
you don't feel hungry.
And I usually use a lot of--
I have five fruits a day,
as much as I can, and
graze throughout the day
instead of having big meals.
But also sleep is important,
and hydration is important.
And what you eat
is also important.
When I'm very disciplined,
when everything's going well,
I am really motivated.
But as soon as I get injured
or something is going wrong,
I just throw in the towel
in terms of nutrition.
That's what I need to be
careful about sometimes.
He let it loose, I guess.
JASON SANDERS: Because
you have a sweet tooth.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: I do
have a sweet tooth.
And I had my banana
nut when I was waiting.
I got here a little
early, so I have to spoil.
And cheesecakes-- strawberry
cheesecake is my one weakness.
So I had that a couple days ago.
So after marathons,
I spoil myself.
So even my girls, especially the
seven-year-old, they're like,
Dad, you can't have sweets.
You're training.
So in fact, she asked me, oh,
I want to have a date with you,
an ice cream date because you
did really good in school.
And I'm like, when am I going
to have that date with her?
Because I'm in training right
now, and I can't have that
date with her.
But I had a really nice date a
couple of days ago, breakfast,
and she had the former
world record come by,
and we had our eggs and stuff.
And they're like, well, if you
want that ice cream now, you
can have it.
But you have to be
very, very disciplined.
Because for me, I'll be 40
on May 5, and I have to--
I weigh myself every day.
Is that cynical?
Probably, but I have to see
exactly where I need to be,
because every pound, two
pounds, make a big difference.
JASON SANDERS: Right.
And so you've been
running competitively
for 25 years,
something like that.
It sounds like
you've learned a lot
over the course of that career.
What's the one thing you wish
you could go back and tell
yourself 25 years ago?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: I think as
an elite athlete, four years
in high school, four
years in college,
and 17 years as a
professional-- yeah,
it's 25 years that I've been
running-- as a professional,
it's very difficult
to take a day off.
You need to work hard, but
also, if you feel something,
you take another day off.
And if I had done those, I could
have saved a couple of injuries
myself.
But we are so driven,
type-A personality, go, go,
go, go, go.
And it's going to get warmed
up after a couple of miles.
And then you're digging
yourself a hole.
So injury prevention,
I think, is--
you know what, if
you take a day off,
nothing will happen to you.
You're probably going to
do yourself a big favor
than do harm if you try to run.
So that's what I
will tell to myself.
JASON SANDERS:
That's good advice.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: I still
need to apply it at times.
JASON SANDERS: I'm nursing
a hamstring strain now,
so this is coming at
the perfect time for me.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
You'd rather just
be one day late to
come than one day early
and lead to more problems.
JASON SANDERS:
That's great advice.
So I mentioned in
the introduction
about your foundation,
the Meb Foundation.
Could you tell us a
little bit about that
and maybe tell us
how we could help?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: When I
was in seventh grade,
that's how my god-given
talents was discovered.
The PE teacher said,
if you run hard,
you're going to get an A
or B. If you mess around,
goof around, you're
getting a D or an F. Well,
I ran hard in PE
class and ran 5:20.
That's where my
god-given talents--
JASON SANDERS: In seventh grade?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
In seventh grade.
And to get the A
and a T-shirt, you
had to run six minutes
and 15 seconds.
So I ran almost
50 seconds faster.
And he said, you're
going to be an Olympian.
But when you don't
speak English,
you don't know what
the Olympics are.
You never watched TV before.
So it was an awkward moment.
But he was right.
I'm still in touch
with Coach Dick Lord.
And I see him occasionally.
He's like, I knew you
were going to do it.
And he called the
high school coach.
And he said-- my two oldest
brothers were running.
This little one is
really, really good.
He's going to be
in the Olympics.
And so due to that, because of
budget cuts with education now,
people are eliminating the
physical education class.
But I think physical education
class is good for the brain,
is good for academics,
for well-balanced.
So through the Meb Foundation,
maintaining excellent balance
through health,
education, and fitness,
we need to give back to kids
to have active lifestyle,
because I think if
you do that, it's
going to help them set goals,
hard work, perseverance,
and also time management.
And that can translate
to academics,
to work ethic, the workforce,
and also positive contributions
to society.
So I just hope to do those works
to be able to-- we've done,
like, we had 11 or 12 people run
the Boston Marathon on behalf
of the Meb Foundation to raise
money and give it to kids.
Some schools, they just
need advice and nutrition
and work ethic and tell
them to give a talk.
But there are
others that we have
given about 7,000
or a pair of shoes,
for others to put a sneaker
on and go for a run who
never had that opportunity.
I myself didn't have that.
My parents couldn't afford
to buy a pair of shoes.
So the coach at Ramos,
he used to provide that.
So we want to help others to
be able to exercise and live
an active lifestyle.
JASON SANDERS: And maybe you'll
train the next generation
of Olympic superstars.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
It'll be an honor
to be able to help others
accomplish a dream.
For me, like you said earlier,
Jason, I've been fortunate.
Boston was the cap of my career.
But I still am a competitive
kind of guy, so I'm like,
2016 is around the corner.
I might as well just
participate and see
if I can earn the top
three to go to Rio.
But after that, it's for me to
help others, help them realize
their potential, whether it's
through motivational speaking
or through coaching
and whether they
want to break five hours for
the marathon or three hours
for the half.
It's just a way
of life, I think.
Sports has done an
amazing journey for me,
and I'm in a position to give
back, and I want to do that.
JASON SANDERS: Great.
Let's hope people are encouraged
to obviously go look up the Meb
Foundation and make donations.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Yeah.
You can go to
marathonmeb.com, and there's
a link for that for
the Meb Foundation.
JASON SANDERS: And
if you can't find it,
just use a search
engine to find it.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Guess what.
I think you can Google it.
JASON SANDERS: Great.
I think we have some time.
If people have questions
they'd like to ask Meb,
please go to one of the two
microphones so that everyone
can hear you.
People seem excited.
And you should feel
free to call on people.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: We'll
rotate, I guess.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Meb, thanks
so much for being here.
And thanks also for being
someone that all of us
average runners can relate to.
Jason brought up the
London situation.
I know I always
think about how you
put the names of the
victims on your bib.
That meant so much
to so many people
and to the people
of Boston that day.
And I just wanted to
personally thank you for that,
fighting through injuries, all
those things we all go through.
I guess this is a
question for us mortals.
And that is, how
would you recommend
that us average runners approach
the first half of a marathon?
I, like you, just ran on
Monday for the seventh time,
and I struggle every time at
Boston and other marathons
with falling apart in the
second half of the race.
Do you recommend
negative splits,
taking it slow the first 5K?
What do you recommend
for that approach?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Michael.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Michael, thanks
for the nice compliments.
I appreciate it.
And I try to be a good
ambassador for the sport.
But in terms of
breaking the marathon,
breaking the segments--
so basically, life
is about patience,
marathon is about patience.
Running a marathon
that day is to test you
if you have the patience,
meaning that any world
record from 5K up
to the marathon
is all about even splits
or slower the first half.
So for me, even Boston, if
I was running by myself,
even expenditure of energy.
And I ran-- I know it's going
to sound fast, but 1:04:19,
1:04:18, with the challenge, of
course, of the Boston Marathon.
So just what I do is
focus on the 13 miles.
You'd rather be within
yourself well beyond,
controlling yourself, oh,
this is still easy for me.
And then you'd rather just
pick it up and finish stronger
than say, you know what--
because it's hard to do,
because you are so
excited, there's
so many people around you.
You want to go, hey, I'm not
going to let that person go.
I'm not going to let that
person get ahead of me.
So the competitive you, you need
to shut down almost your mind
until the 13 miles, 15
miles, and after that say,
you know what,
it's game time now.
I'm going to be
able to run faster,
and we'll try to negative split.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks so much for the advice
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No
problem, Michael.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a similar
question on that.
So you did touch upon the topic
that the advice kind of depends
on where you are.
And sometimes giving
advice can bite you back,
hey, I didn't know
enough about the person.
So similarly, like you spaced
out the zoning and the race,
how do you say, hey,
you are at level this
and you are at level
this, and you are at level
this, now you
should do this next?
Because depending on your level,
what you have already done,
that's how your
recovery should be.
And that's how much icing--
like, 15 minutes every day,
probably not so much if someone
is running once in a year.
So how do you give
the advice depending
on where the person is?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: That's
an excellent question.
What's your name again?
AUDIENCE: [? Aditieu ?].
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: What is it?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: [? Aditieu ?].
You know, the 15 minutes
and the ice bath,
that's like on hard days.
I would concentrated--
you guys are busy,
and I have to meet criteria.
I have almost 24
hours of my profession
to do the small
details, take my time.
But for you, it's maybe
stretching on the easy days.
And maybe when you do
a long run, maybe once
a week or every two weeks,
you need to do the ice bath.
Or if you do your
tempo run or race pace,
you need to do the ice
bath-- not every day.
And in terms of
setting goals, you
have to be yourself
and say, you know what?
I just want to run 25
miles for the week.
I want to do that
four weeks in a row.
And then once you get--
you can see yourself.
If you do four weeks,
you're going to do stronger.
It's time for me to
increase it by two miles,
and I want to do that
for two or three weeks.
And then, say, seven
weeks or nine weeks,
I want to run 13
miles my long run.
You started with
three, four miles.
But in eight weeks,
it's attainable.
It's not undoable,
but you've got
to be very careful to make the
increments move a little bit
versus, I'm going to do
it and Meb said this.
You have to know
yourself and consult
with your coach and other people
that you're around with to say,
you know what?
I want to achieve this.
And how can I do that?
And then if you
put it in writing,
you're going to achieve
it, just because it's
positive reinforcement.
I love doing my train log.
I have a train log since '93.
I'm like, this week I just
want to put 50 miles a week.
Like, right now I'm not running
after the Boston Marathon.
I'm debating when to run.
I'd rather be one day too
late than one day too early.
And then after that, it'll
be two, three days a week
I'll run every other day.
And then after that,
I say, my body's OK.
I'm going to try
to run every day.
And then slowly,
maybe 35 miles a week.
And then once you do that, you
become strong enough to say,
OK, I'm ready to step
it up another notch.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No problem.
Good luck.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Meb.
Thanks for coming in today.
I have a time
management question.
So obviously, to train takes
a lot of time every day.
And I know you have a
family, three daughters.
I struggle with
having a child myself.
Like, either I would
spend time with my child
after work, which is an
investment in her future,
or I would-- kind of, yeah.
Or I would run or train or go
to the gym and invest in myself.
So I kind of feel,
it's a little bit--
I know it's wrong at some point,
but how do you manage that?
Like, does your family
support you in your effort?
And what do you tell them
when you spend so much time
training, which is a very
good thing, but I mean,
I would appreciate
an advice on how
do you make them understand
that this is very important?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Well, I've
been very fortunate to surround
myself with good team.
So my brother is here, my wife.
She gave up her
career so I could
have the career that I
have, because as an athlete,
it's limited time.
So to be a parent, she's
spending a lot of time
with her.
But sometimes I'll
give her a break
when I'm on break after a
marathon or things like that.
I let her do her thing,
and I'll go to the park.
You don't have to
do that every day.
But if you say, you know what,
I'll meet you at the park.
After a run, bring
the kids down.
And then while you do your
stretching, put them on a swing
and spend time with them, that's
going to be more valuable.
And it depends how
old the kid is.
And sometimes I'll tell my wife,
here, don't worry about it.
I'll get up early
in the morning when
I can, take them to school,
bring them from school.
I might do that for a
week, a week and a half,
when I'm in San Diego, whereas
right now I can't do that.
So Daddy, you're
traveling again?
I hear that a little
bit sometimes.
And I say, yes, but I'll
be back in nine days.
And I would love to do-- you
know, share your story, what
you have been doing.
I will catch up with you.
So you have to have a balance.
I personally try
to live by my name,
maintain excellent balance.
You know, you'd love to be there
for your family, your wife,
your kids, all the time.
But at the same time,
job gets in the way,
training gets in the way,
and travel gets in the way.
So I try to make the
most of it when you can,
because those are profound
times of kids' life.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess the good point
is that you set an example
for your kids to follow.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Yeah.
You know, when I take
exercise, sometimes I
tell my kids they have a
little disadvantage because I
tell my wife, bring
them here, if I'm
doing [INAUDIBLE] course,
two and a half mile loops,
every time I do that,
they want to run with me.
But they know that I'm going
six minute pace on my recovery
runs.
So they hang out
with me for 50 meters
and I'll say, go, go, go,
keep going so I could catch up
to them, you know?
But then at the
end, I'll spend time
with them doing strides or
doing a run with them whatever
pace they want.
And sometimes out of the
blue, they will ask you, Dad,
can you run around
the block with us?
And if I'm home, as long as
they ask, I'll do that for them.
Just, when they
demand it, you've
got to be there for them.
But other times, I just explain,
sorry, but I have to travel.
I have to do this.
And they usually understand.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Jesus.
I did the New York Marathon
last year and the year before.
I did not do it officially, like
I started before it officially
started.
But I managed to do it in, the
first time, two hours and 15
minutes, and the second time
in one hour, 57 minutes.
I did it on a bike.
And at that point I realized
that you guys are superhumans.
It was hard.
We had, like, a really hard
pace to keep on the bike.
And it was almost impossible.
I mean, we had some traffic,
but it was really hard.
So I realize that doing it
in under two hours running,
it's an accomplishment
that is out of this world.
But have you ever had
that goal in your head?
And do you think it's going
to happen sometime soon?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: At least
you have a perspective
of what pace you're going?
JASON SANDERS: Have you ever
considered just using a bike?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No, I have
people pace me for my training.
I have people on the bike.
So I can catch most people
going up hills on the bike.
So I race against them,
especially on trails.
And they zoom down with
me on the downhill.
And I'm like, I know the course,
there's another uphill coming.
So I close the gap and then
try to catch them again.
And I have people on my long
run, tempo, and intervals.
But is it possible to
break the two hours?
I think it is, as long
as-- unfortunately,
like I said earlier,
there are some people
that have not done it clean.
Sometimes you hear--
but the consistency
from-- before I started running
was 2:04:55, now it's 2:02:38,
I believe.
It's going down, going
down pretty drastically.
And obviously, it'll be
like Roger Bannister, where
he broke the four minute,
and then many people
started doing it.
Is it going to happen?
I think it can happen.
But as female use
male pacers, we
need you as male
pacemakers on the bike
and give us drinks whenever.
If people are concerned
about winning,
I have to beat that guy and
that guy, you are by yourself,
you're going to slow.
But if you are not
concerned the [INAUDIBLE] is
going to slow down, you can
get closer to two hours.
So I say, hey, Jesus is my guy.
I say, pick it up.
Let's surge.
And somebody else has
their own or whatever.
The reward for breaking
it versus for getting
second place, first
place, and all that stuff.
So if that happens,
I think it can.
Can it happen when?
Probably on our
lifetime, I think
it's going down pretty quickly.
And we have a guy
where I was born,
in Eritrea, the guy that
ran 58:23, I believe,
for the half marathon.
So if someone like him
that has the talent
runs two hours, that's
a minute and a half,
that's 10 seconds per mile
slowing down on a flat course.
You need to go an hour
and then run 59, 58.
It can't be, like, 59 and
then go the other way around.
You have to negative split it.
And I think it can happen.
AUDIENCE: And have you had it
as a goal in your life to do it?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: You know, I
think it was "Runner's World,"
they had an article what
the criteria of that person
would be and what
height, what weight,
and it kind of sounded like me.
It really did.
But that was,
like, 13, 14, years
ago, so you need to be 27.
And it described a lot
about what I have done,
what the training, and what the
height and all that stuff is,
and the weight and all that.
But no, it's never been my goal.
It's too late to think
about that goal now.
I'm just trying to stay healthy
and get to that finish line.
But yeah, if somebody who
is 5'6, 119, 121 pounds,
and would have a
VO2 max of high,
we can see it
happen potentially.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi Med,
my name is Katie.
It's really nice to meet you.
I've been a long time
fan, so it's really cool
that you're here at Google.
In full disclosure, I work
on the Lifestyle Fashion team
here, and Skechers
is one of my clients.
So I can attest to the
fact that they really
do love you at Skechers,
and they're so proud of you.
So my question is
kind of twofold.
The first is, how important is
it to have the right equipment?
And what impact does having
the wrong equipment make?
And then also, when you
signed with Skechers,
what was the feedback you got
from the running community?
Because they're
not a Nike or maybe
one of the more serious
brands-- at least back then,
hopefully that will change.
But I'm just curious about
how you choose a sponsor
and how important
the equipment is.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Great.
Thanks, Katie.
Nice to meet you.
Choosing a sponsorship is huge.
And for me, I have
to be very authentic.
In fact, with Skechers, we met
with them in January of 2011,
and I met with Robert Greenberg
and Michael Greenberg.
And I say, you know, I
need more a partnership
than a sponsorship,
because I really
believe I have half
marathon and marathon PRs.
I can't guarantee
you in the 5K, 10K.
That might be behind me.
But I need you to
help me design shoes.
But there was
shoes call ProSpeed
that I use just recreational.
And I'm like, I ran 20 miles.
They go, you did?
And then we use that.
And then basically, as you can
see in the picture, the Go Meb
Speed 3 there, we probably
made 40 pair of shoes
with that before
that final one there.
We had the Go Meb
Speed 3, I helped
them design the firmness.
Then we eventually even put
carbon fiber in it to make it
stiffer, lightweight,
and very narrow.
Because I mean, the tongue,
where you kind of land and then
kind of come up,
we have-- it was
so low that I had to
give input that says you
need that roll off, roll off.
And then we had to work
from the lacing, how
long the lace should be, and
kind of starting from scratch.
And also, when
you tie the shoes,
there's no more ripple
almost, like crunched up.
So we have to make
sure we smooth it out.
So it was a lot of work.
But they want my input.
I give them my input.
And to run a personal best
that first time when I
ran the New York City Marathon.
And not many people remember,
but I'm pointing at the clock.
I said, I ran faster
than I every did.
And then eventually going to the
trials, going to the Olympics,
finishing fourth.
So it says a lot about them.
It also says a lot about me,
to teamwork or partnership,
to be able to just achieve.
And what the people say
when I first wore Skechers,
they were very skeptical.
Some people are still skeptical.
And they see them in my trunk
of my car, and they said,
do you really wear Skechers?
I'm like, I just pop
the trunk, and there's
like a kazillion pairs there.
And then sometimes-- I
remember this vivid moment.
It was Christmas,
probably, 2012 or 2011.
I was running on Christmas
Day by my sister's house
in San Diego.
And the person goes, I can't
believe I'm running with Med.
Is that really you?
She's watching my watch,
watching my socks,
watching my shoes, Skechers.
She's like, it is really you.
So you do really wear Skechers.
But every sponsor that I
do, I'm very authentic.
I try them out beforehand.
And hopefully it's
a win-win situation.
And I hope to be a brand
ambassador for them
for a long time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Thanks, Katie.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Meb.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
And I wanted to ask you a little
bit about your perspective
at the front of
the field competing
against the other
elite athletes.
And in particular, with the
resurgence of American distance
running in recent
years, especially
in the longer
events, sometimes we
see American athletes in
the middle of the race surge
to the front, hold the lead.
And the announcers and
such are super-excited.
We saw this this year
with Dathan and Desi
in Boston, and in other
races in the past.
And I was curious
as to your thoughts
about in terms of strategy,
in terms of what kind
of goes on upfront in the pack.
You mentioned earlier you
spoke Italian to the one guy.
Like, how much chatter
happens up there?
You guys are running
a marathon pace,
so it is not
conversational, but you guys
can talk, in spite of
going extraordinary speeds.
And so I was curious about
your perspective up there.
How does strategy play into
that while you guys are sort
of working together, sort of
trying to account for the wind,
surges, et cetera?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Full disclosure,
I didn't see Desi's race,
but she ran a great
race, from fourth place.
In terms of Dathan,
it's always encouraging
to have your
countryman next to you.
It just makes it a
little bit easier.
So if you find somebody from
Google on a plane or something,
you try to get to
talk to them, oh, we
work for the same
company, you're
more relaxed-- versus who's
that person kind of thing.
So similarly, when you're
running, competing,
you're trying to
push the envelope,
and they're thinking
from behind.
And I thought at one point, I
thought that he was struggling
or we made the gap, and I didn't
think he was going to catch up.
And then he came, and he
went to the lead right away.
I'm like, that was
tactically not the best thing
just because it was windy.
If it was not
windy, I would have
been not forced but
encouraged to go with him
and work as a team in dialogue.
And Ethiopian, in
fact, four of them,
they were talking to each other.
And I'm like, nope, I'm
going to get close to you,
because if you spread
apart a little bit,
they're going to encourage each
other to go faster because you
show them sign of struggle.
But if you're next to
them, then it's like, oh,
we haven't really maxed this
guy out of his potential yet.
So you have to-- unwritten
rules to be able to follow that.
And then the Kenyans were
doing the same thing.
And just, whenever
they were talking,
the other Kenyans or Ethiopians,
I just says, buckle your belt.
There's going to be a big
move coming sometime soon.
So be ready.
And Dathan ran well.
It's always good to see the
transition to a 5K, 10K,
through the marathon.
And Ryan Hall, we've
done that some last year.
And Abdi and Culpepper and Abdi
Abdirahman and Alan Culpepper,
we used to do that ourselves,
changing leads and this
and this, our work together.
And it's always-- you know,
there's no trash talking.
But sometimes there's gestures,
because somebody kind of
tapped you from behind.
You're like, be careful.
And sometimes there's a lot of
juggling at the fluid stations
and things like that.
So it's good to see that
US distance runners be up
in the front, just because
hopefully I can be an example,
Deena Kastor can be an example
that we have one major-- like,
she won London and Chicago.
I won Boston and New York.
And an Olympic
medal, both of us.
I say, if we can do it, we
all started here in the US.
I might be born elsewhere,
but all my training,
all my time came here, so we
can be an example with league
champion, NCAA and
USA champion, and then
major marathon champion.
So they can be, hey, if they
can do it, we can do it.
AUDIENCE: Thank a lot, Meb.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
Thank you for being
here this afternoon.
So I was out for a morning
run not too long ago,
and another runner
synced up with me.
And speaking of chatter,
we got into a conversation.
And they asked me if I
was training for anything.
And I said no, I'm not.
I've kind of decided not to
do anything terribly difficult
this year.
And it made me realize how
much joy there is in that.
Like, I didn't have to
worry so much about, oh, I
have to always beat this pace.
Or you talked about the
watch and this equipment.
I'm kind of curious how
much you, or people, should
let their equipment dictate
to them how much they should
be pushing themselves
or worrying about that
versus how often even
you might get out
to just run for the fun of it.
We talked about kids.
If you ever go to a
playground with your kids,
you just see all these
kids running around.
They're just active
for the joy of it.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Ed.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: Ed.
You know, in "Meb For Mortals,"
that's what I try to portray.
All the drills that
I have in there,
illustrations, like
being a kid again.
Because sometimes we
get so serious to train,
I've got to run these miles,
and I've got to do this
and I've got to do that.
But at the same time, there's
days where in the evening runs,
I'm not worried about pace.
I'm just out for my evening
runs, just enjoy your sunset,
or enjoy just a run at
the beach and whatnot,
because I'm not
worried about time.
But there's three times
a week that's probably,
I'm like, I'm on the clock.
Other than that,
it's just pure joy.
I love doing it.
And I want to be
able to-- and I have
my watch on heart
rate screen and try
to guess what pace I'm going.
And vice versa, I will
have it on the pace
and then guess what
my heart rate is.
So you have to use
technology to your advantage,
see if you have recovered from
the hard day the day before,
so by looking at heart rate.
But then there are other times,
it's just like, you know what?
I'm not going to see my watch
for the next three miles.
I just want to see my
body, how it feels.
And you kind of go from there.
But yeah, being a
kid, like you said,
those drills and things
like that-- we are so
going to go forward.
We don't go lateral or backward.
I mean, I don't know when
the last time some of you
guys went backward.
It's been a long time, probably.
So that's what the
drills emphasize.
We use the other muscles
than just the front
and try to have fun
at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No problem, Ed.
JASON SANDERS: I think we have
time for one more question.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: I'll
make a short answer.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Meb.
My name's Bridget.
And my dad's a PE
teacher, so I loved
hearing your story about PE.
It sounds like
something he would
say about how important
it is for your whole life
and how important it
is to stay in schools.
But you also talked
about your coaches.
You talked about your
parents and their reaction
to your racing.
And I'm wondering now
that you're a parent
and you have daughters,
what do you want for them?
Do you want them to be distance
runners or Pele or none
of the above?
MEB KEFLEZIGHI:
Yordanos, my wife, and I
encourage them to
do different sports.
They already have
participated in soccer.
We want them to be outdoors.
And we will support them
to whatever their goal is.
And if they do become
runners, they're
going to get good advice.
But the middle one, Fiyori,
you can see a little bit
enthusiasm, you can see
discipline and dedication.
When I'm at the house,
she's always following me.
She's my assistant, helping
me out, getting me that,
stretching with me, core with
me, and planks with me and all.
So the other two,
you kind of have
to convince them to come in.
But as long as, whether it's
soccer or tennis or softball,
whatever it is, hopefully they
can be outdoor and participate.
But if I have to
choose, I'll probably
tell them to play tennis because
I love tennis and watching it
and whatnot.
But running is lonely,
it's hard work--
not that the other
sports are not,
but you have to have
the self-discipline
to be able to
achieve those things.
But first and foremost,
academics comes first,
because I did not give
running a priority
until I graduated from UCLA,
because I was one injury away,
or I don't want to get injured.
And you never know if
you're going to make it.
My mom always says, the person
thinks it, God finishes it.
And I just tried to do the
right things every time.
And I've been overjoyed
to what that the running,
from physical education, has
taken me around the world
and be able to
write books and be
able to enjoy the
lifestyle of being fit,
which is good for the head,
for the mind, and for the body.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
MEB KEFLEZIGHI: No problem.
JASON SANDERS: Thank you, Meb.
I think that's all
we have time for.
Will you be around
after to sign?
[APPLAUSE]